you
you
yeah hello and welcome to this stream I
hope it works fine hope it does right
and welcome to all of you in the chat
yeah I have now installed this little
intro picture for the stream I think it
makes sense start with this intro screen
and see that actually some people are
actually on before I get the actual
video rolling so doing a little bit of a
spontaneous stream tonight I did
something similar and last week on
Friday kind of the end of the week
stream so I'm going to play some games
today and let's make it quick games yeah
some quick games here against viewers so
let's challenge challenge me and make
sure we are playing let's say up to
three minutes per game yeah so let's
like three plus three plus zero is the
maximum then I want to play so that we
get some games and then we get some
games played yeah let's stop do it with
the three plus two let's do two plus one
or three plus zero that it adds to three
so we get a couple of games on that
would be cool
right I've done some longer games yeah
three plus zero is good let's do that
I've done some longer games in the past
but this way you can also challenge me
to two bullet it's fine just want to get
more more games more games in too short
okay yeah then then maybe next time and
also what I wanted to I wanted to
mention I have thought about the
subscribers the subscribers currently
get
I can use the emote that now thankfully
works but other than that they don't
have much of an advantage being a
subscriber so what I am now doing is
when we do the viewer games playing
against twitch viewers I want to accept
the challenges of the subscribers first
so as long as there are subscribers
challenging I'm going to take those
challenges first I think this is a good
way to give an additional give something
back to the people that support twitch
stream the twitch channel by subscribing
I will still play the non subscribers
but you have to let's say wait a little
bit longer
so this is a nice position I think I
feel uncomfortable or pieces look
refined oh that looks like it's somewhat
that looks loose let's say thanks for
subscribing
stylee that's stylee right yeah yeah I
can go a four here in this position I'm
sure that it helps so much
oh it looks weird it looks wrong somehow
for what like I should have some sort of
trickery but I don't see anything deform
bishop takes and then I can actually
take you to okay
can take on f6 anyway let's do it
an on exchange French you don't like to
play against the exchange French it's
annoying to you then I've done a good
job there with this choice yeah you can
I can't play something else if you like
yeah I am winning too much material
thanks for the game chess and stuff so
what I'm going to do is you see the list
of challenges yeah I'm going from top to
bottom so the oldest will will play
first the oldest challenge but I will
take make priority the subscribers so
Feynman is a subscriber so I play him
first
and then I'll place tiny also subscriber
but if there are no subscribers in the
list I'm going to go on top again I
think this is fair so let's go this is
one of chess okay
okay and this Bishop doesn't have a good
square so I think I'm going to get this
and let's put some pressure on three six
maybe 95 I don't know he gives me the
pawn give to me the pawn as yes ss so
I'm happy with this ending just being a
pawn up g3 is stopping any exchanges and
now I try to get the pawns rolling and
c5 was maybe attention aim to be honest
not sure that I would repeat this
decision okay it's a little bit a little
bit uncomfortable okay here I think I
will take and go to f4 because blacks
Bishop just have absolutely nowhere to
go chill I know threatenings is several
and looks a bit odd I have kind of
forgotten that this is a college game
yeah so he resigned at the end but I
think him I was yeah I was accelerating
early enough and no rematches please
let's go stylee if you if you're
challenging me currently and you are
subscriber and you don't have the same
name
in the chat please make sure to tell me
what your name here on beaches is so
that I can actually identify you
otherwise a little bit tricky to do this
is looks like a nice position for white
97 as some of you probably want to play
and it looks looks a bit odd so if I
take this and play this Oh 25 hello
I overlooked Queen to d5 but okay 92 a
92 I can play but this is just about
before was saying was check ninety of
six wasn't bad I think no just that was
a little bit too late
the French exchange is often annoying
for the French player because they don't
get to play their close positions where
they can play around with the standard
porn break C 5 f6 all that is gone in
the French exchange and this is why it
often is annoying it's also a little bit
boring anyway and then also is a problem
for some players yeah here this is a
nice position
I've got good pressure against ecigs
trying for c4 now and our Queen 36 now
has to be played and after that I'm
going to double on the e-file let's just
try that like it's taking some time to a
thought 26 husband forced almost yep
yeah now I have to watch out there Queen
takes c5 is a is an idea huh okay yeah
let's go back for mode this is just
temporary
c5 an idea I'm sorry II five is that an
idea maybe
[Music]
yeah e6 is not unprotected it's now
unprotected that's what I was trying to
say yeah thanks for the game Stinney
anybody else challenging Romania is
challenging so and he's a subscriber so
let's do that for that we at first yeah
it was a really pretty bad position you
got there stylee
so my c-45 pet line
yeah I like that for black it's not so
easy to play it on
I only a very short while ago was
looking at a game of one of my students
and he had a good position with that Wow
d5 Thanks
the others will definitely play I mean
it just said I'm going to play against
some of the subscribers and but they are
not that many you know I think after
this game yeah thanks for the
subscription brave Bavarian if you have
if you have a challenge out you need to
give me your your name as there's not
brave Bavarian in but it will still be
possible for the non subscribers to play
for sure
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] let's get this question
rolling has got a question regarding c4
but it says it's not a very good
question so now you never know probably
it is a good question okay I tried to
get rid of this week upon my head isn't
that shiny actually it's first of all
you don't do anything anything to do it
it's just I always before I am decided
to get rid of the love of the the hair I
was always thinking that yeah people who
[Music]
look extremely shinier that they that
they do anything to do to get to get to
the state but it's simply not it's
simply not the case
it just happens naturally I can't put
some pressure on to the 6 mm not so easy
[Music]
[Music]
don't like that so much good defense
here by Romanian
Percy says in six we have to play much
higher rated play a place once before
and so do I he plays if I began c-4 I've
been studying my he's been studying my
stress of a repertoire any ideas for
both colors so first you don't know what
color you have against two more you
already know that you've got whiter
black that's it it's kind of important
or you only know who you're playing but
you don't know the color this is a very
important point possible to resist all
those pawns
[Music]
I don't know it's a team moment thanks
for the game Ramon Yin so is there any
any challenge bye bye subscribe I don't
know if you are subscribed I haven't
played yet and are challenging me I
don't see it somehow let me know yeah
your name is Rosa but you're not a
subscriber ok 94 so I'm taking and this
is a pretty comfortable position this is
topless one ah-hoo Bishop c4 I was
thinking as somehow saw Queen to b6 I
know it sounds silly but there was a big
blunder
King Kong Harlan he could have taken my
bishop for absolutely nothing
I was indeed a very close call okay I
think I'm going a five no he gives me
peace I'll take it and already resigned
thanks for the game King Kong Hari so
ideal phobia I wanted to limit it to
zero I mean just three minutes can we go
for three minutes please
so then I get more games in I want to
play as many as many opponents as
possible yeah thanks for playing
Romanian this was a bit too quick I
understand
instead I try to do different time
controls in those viewer challenges and
this time I want to play a somewhat
wicked game so that we got more more
games in one point is also that I'm not
going to me going to be on super long
tonight I'm intending for roughly two
hours and not for super long stream so
they must solve the question by Percy
Hepworth
there are c4 players both of them and he
doesn't know what what to do okay
against 1c form I absolutely like them
the line that I'm playing with black in
the c-45 line with if possible with
knight c6 Bishop c5 c6 a6 Bishop e7 the
line that had on earlier like three
three or four games ago this is a line
that the white players still don't know
that well and they often
unfamiliar with the position types
something I would definitely recommend
from black if you are white and you know
is going to play c-45 yeah oh my it's
not so easy to say if I can a couple of
things I don't know how much you know
already about the different lines I
would still go g3 probably and yeah try
to polish those lines the other way that
you could do is if they definitely play
c-45 you can also try to surprise them a
little bit by playing somewhat and
common variation something like let's
say with either than early III with an
early a3 those lines are fully fully
playable and they are oftentimes simply
not so well known by black so C 4 e 5
and then stuff like III a3 and so on
this is kind of interesting it's not
going to be as threatening as g3 but
sometimes surprise can can help okay
between the board CM has an IQ p
position isolated pawn position and it's
doing a pretty good job I try to somehow
until it's not so easy to do I would
like to get rid of this knight on e5
this is what I was planning looks kind
of shaky though
[Music]
thanks for subscribing fire-breathing
dragon you challenging me I will check
it ok after f6 the White Knight has to
drop back I was a little bit reluctant
to play that because it looks shaky my
position a little bit shake him I was
wondering if b6 is right here yeah let's
do it
this night is so annoying ok I'm going
to kick his book I would or let's say I
try to do that it's not so easy to do
[Music]
poor I tried to go look e8o no what's he
doing here
taking this
okay we have to speed up here both of us
I'm on that okay I think I've got it
under control now okay thanks for the
game between the board's that was well
played I have to defend the whole time
okay so anybody around probably not just
beginner it's good default
try something else there I don't play
the London usually but can do it once in
a while
hello to would scratch and there's been
a discussion in the in the chat if chess
or komodo chess is the superior platform
yeah I mean with this the subject this
is endless yeah there are always
somewhat different views and there
what's so different things that people
that people like even though I'm I'm
fairly certain if you if you ask people
from chess calm and they don't give you
any marketing chitchat and they would is
they would certainly admit that reaches
is the better programmed interface this
is not something to discuss this is just
reality I mean if you know a little bit
how programming works yeah you see that
the purely playing experiences is vastly
superior and I mean nobody would admit
that from the chess calm let's say Board
of Directors or have wherever you ask
but it's just fairly certain yeah but
anyway it's also not a problem I mean if
you like to play on on on chess calm why
not do it it's solely fine okay anyway
let's see what's going on you can just
go of course I know you're not a
subscriber yeah I would still play you
if you go to 3-0
and it is there are different there are
different kind of things to consider
when you think about those servers it's
about different oh that's a big night
ticket it's not about just the playing
experience the playing the pure playing
of chess is definitely better I think on
only chess yeah I mean it's a very sleek
interface it's quick there's no no no
lack it just works fantastically however
watch Escom is doing for chess in
general with all these events that they
that they're doing is fantastic it's
absolutely fantastic I'm actually doing
this the wrong way er then you
challenges our top right I should go
here the approach has League is
fantastic towels use things are great
yeah they also do do the those for the
court the speed chess stuff yeah it's
great it's great I mean just the
coverage of all those things are great
the service all have their pros and cons
chess 24 for example SS is excellent for
for the video content yeah however the
playing is um yeah top and I'm screwing
this up whole time the ones on top yeah
the old ones on top right now yeah I
play I'm sorry squad deck and sometimes
confused it just like I'm confused okay
the old ones on top sorry it's um the
thing is I have the same when I do those
on
on chest 24 I think it's the other way
around
now the service they all have their pros
and cons in some way the ICC for example
has the strongest player pool it's just
what it is they have huge a huge chunk
of title players that you can play
against like the 5 minute pool is very
strong from your pool is very strong it
all has their pros and cons so and I
don't really mind let's say if if
streamers decide to play to play on
chess calm for example it's it's it's
it's it's there's nothing wrong about
that I was some I was talking to chess
calm as well for for streaming but the
thing is I'm playing I mean I stream me
playing chess and I just enjoyed the
playing more here because it's just a
nice experience to do it on the server
on D chair so I decided to be here it's
not there wasn't some what I know it
wasn't a decision about liking something
or liking a company or anything like
that you said the playing experience is
good here so I saw no way to change
so yeah good game here by yo-yo flow
there is I don't what leaches has again
the best the best playing experience I
think in purely terms of playing there
is not much to improve just just
excellent it's not a full it's not a
website it's on a website that you
should directly compare with with the
with the product like like chess or
comma or chess 24 because teachers for
example doesn't have videos and there's
no premium content in a way it's just
it's just just a bit it's just a bit
different it has a different different
focus and bleaches does not need to be
competitive on all levels with those
other sites it doesn't have to be there
just just a bit it's just a different
concept so how am I going to play this
how do I play this I should play quickly
is the thing I think the playing pool on
ICC is still extremely strong yes all
right we'll play b3 and I have to be
ready to oh my queen
ah okay Oh 93 I did not have that on the
on the radar who would game
yo-yo flow so we are going to start huh
how was it coming up square dick square
deck
it's place critic I'm not quite sure of
that there was the right number so what
I said it's just cool it okay I have to
focus on that game no way of chatting
during a big bullet game okay soon I'm
sure
oh it was very helpful
I know take the exchange the tech is a
lot stronger what do you need to the
drunken lawyer hope you're not too drunk
this is bullet I'm such a that she
impractical player sometimes simply
taking too long I can't be happy that
he's taking a very long as well no one
that was lucky okay so any questions
around there not quite sure made any
chess legends um well not sure what what
what you would qualify as a legend I
think I played last year played blast
him in horde who's a very well-known
player of course in Germany
I mean meeting Petrosian is a bit
difficult for me yes because he died in
1984 and then now I was 10 years old I
wasn't even even playing chess the
player but I could have met
unfortunately did not meet is tall that
actually could have happened because tal
um played part out played for the German
Bundesliga team of Cologne and they
cologne had an open tournament for some
years and actually a tournament that I
played in but unfortunately the years
that I played tall did not play so it
was kind of it was close it could have
happened he was actually many people
that I know met him and they all I meet
al is such a legend and everybody that I
talked about says he was the most
likable person you can imagine a
fantastic fantastic person should my
friendly and and and forthcoming ok this
had an idea and it was this mate yeah
thanks for the game phone do probably
not pronouncing it correctly so three
plus two is a bit long
yeah okay it's yeah
unfortunately I did not did not medium
that would have been fantastic of course
but it didn't happen
them a memory that is still very much in
my mind is that Todd died in the summer
of 1992 and in 1992 the world
Junior I said youth championship was
played in in Duisburg the city that I
was living in and that was like under 10
under 12 under 14 under-16 under-18
everything but under 20 and Todd died
one or two days before they started that
event and I still remember that before
the very first round there was an
announcement that there should be a
moment a minute of silence in honor of
the great great player and it was it was
very memorable moment because all the
kids which is difficult of course and
there that soon they they needed to stay
silent but it somehow worked yeah I
don't think they could have really known
or understood somewhat of like under 10
under 12 1 what happened but it was very
memorable
okay I try to in the way black Here I am
okay yeah it kind of worked that minute
of silence that somehow worked yeah it's
a question by you your flow worms
he's got nineteen hundred reading at
seventy years old and what are tips to
break through the higher chess barriers
besides doing tactics you know doing
Texas doing tactics make some make sense
for every player actually being a
technically alert but who would 1900 you
should also playing a lot makes makes a
lot of sense and I know it sounds very
simple but it does make a difference and
I also donation thanks a lot happy
Friday ok so what am I going to do I try
to
try to make black suffer here with with
immobile pieces and we are playing a lot
make sense to improve and I think in
many cases I know it sounds very simple
but it it makes sense to study the
things that you enjoy doing I know it
sounds very simple and a play level of
1900 there's a wide range of things that
would would improve your game basically
basically anything that you will study
will improve your chairs even things
that don't make much sense I mean if you
understand what I mean
even even if it is like not the best
possible thing to do it would still help
you so you couldn't simply study the
things that you like if you if you enjoy
mostly doing middlegame studies you can
do that even what is very unpopular
amongst many people you can also study
openings and it's nothing particularly
wrong with it as long as you also do
other things
okay so now threatening a5 trapping the
Queen that's going to be kind of cool to
prevent a caribou could be one looks
good
yeah it could have taken immediately but
that looks pretty pretty strong well
what are we doing here
celebrity chance gossip yeah it's kind
of unavoidable sometimes if you if you
listen to or watch those streams you get
get to know things like what what's
what's going on with Carl and his
girlfriend and whatever and okay so I
think I'll just take on g7 it's it's a
very simple solution
okay Scott did not take once III was
check I was expecting that to happen but
didn't do it is this checkmate I didn't
see him made did I haven't made my
didn't see her we should make six that
could have been attractive there's true
my main goal here was simply to keep the
black pieces boxed in I think that works
quite okay
I wish should have thought about that
that gives his rook all of a sudden some
activity oh that wasn't a good decision
not a good decision it's still a fairly
good good I'm still in fairly good shape
so I'm trying the same unsuccessfully
okay so chicky-chicky seven or you know
c6 is also attractive I can also give g2
up but it's really unnecessary
black is running out of moves on okay
now I can get this
Oh check play for meat I think I'm
playing for me at home yeah scar running
out of time thanks for playing so it's a
huge list Archer oh yeah I wanted to go
three minute actually it's the advice of
playing open games before for anything
else useful or just a cliche um I don't
know I think it's not a bad idea to
start with more tactical play like
before open games make some sense there
but I usually think that whenever I'm
dealing with with students and they ask
me what to play oh well thanks for the
donation brave Bavarian I usually don't
point them towards playing a certain
opening as long as what they are playing
is considered to be a sound and good I'm
but I'm okay with it
thanks for subscribing square deck
I actually screwed up the move over here
a little bit I did not want to go into
this
[Music]
so it's a little bit awkward him yeah
emotes are available I mean one here I
can only have one at the moment it
depends on the on the subscriber count'
yeah okay so I'm kind of I'm kind of the
chat is very very lively it's it's tough
to meet tough for me to read it
thanks for subscribing news of blitzed
NIMS oh let's yes
yeah more subscribers seems to mean more
emotes yeah I'm I'm you too all that so
I hope I am see this correctly
okay I'm trying to double on the e-file
good game here by Nirvana new on Niven
Raymond I hope you like the emote I've
worked hard to create it
[Laughter]
yeah mm on the e-file deliver God's I
have to double on the F file yeah I
really have to but somehow I don't I
don't feel I don't understand position
on f6 they have ecigs
the negative space and the new mode what
is the negative space
yeah the transparent yes hmm
I see what I see what I mean I only saw
that the thing is um with the emotes you
have to submit them to to twitch you
cannot just set it yeah yeah you you
basically submit submitted and after
while they approve of it or not and I
had to has some submitted the emote and
only after I had done so I recognized
that a transparent background is is
better and I'm not entirely sure if I
now if I can just do it do it and do it
again
I probably can yeah but I don't want to
let's say deactivate to this one which
is kind of okay at least I understand
the other one is better so but I was
thinking I should do this again once I
get a second emote once they have a
second emote available
okay that's a good move actually they
have to be quick because we could be
dead
yeah I need to speed up 11 seconds but I
think I'm okay okay thanks for the game
yebin Raymond that was tough it was
really tough so I will definitely take
care of the of the of the emo thing I
understand that it's better to have it
transparent absolutely and it's there
any subscriber already or still
challenging me that I should play let me
know in and play and then and also and
played you already that would be a bit
cool
so 93 86 unsound night except 7 yeah I
should prepare that then what the heck
is that what the heck is mad that's
extremely cool
[Laughter]
okay I'm scared
[Music]
[Music]
I'm kind of I tried to get my head
around the fact that this guy seems to
sacrifice a piece for absolutely nothing
how is that going - I said possible I'm
just a piece up I mean okay my my pieces
I had a little bit passive a little bit
but yeah it's sweet wins a baby wins a
Barney I I agree it's a pawn but still I
care it wasn't the cleverest move here
probably but I wanted to open up this
position and the bishop on g7 sucks
it really does
I'm blundering by success not good but
at least I'm getting I'm getting a
little bit of activity my pieces are
active now the g7 bishop is gone and the
rainy remaining pieces coordinate quite
quite well I think
oh that was the idea
he completely he completely put me
asleep with this game
no sorry and it was just like I wasn't
paying attention anymore because tonight
except seven is so ridiculous I didn't
see Queenie three I simply didn't pay
any attention never meant it's a
strategy aptitude to do - completely -
completely yeah you can play 100 games
in 99 that was the one that she lose him
great great great
yeah it must be funny to play like this
fu you lose all the games but then you
have the odd game where people simply
don't pay attention any before because
it's all so awful and I didn't ever move
left rook cd8 my room that's maybe true
I don't know how is 2200 it shouldn't it
should not happen but this strategy
and why is that possible yeah you have
to have to pay attention no matter how
ridiculous it is yeah and yeah I did do
that
I wonder if I can somehow somehow play
against the weird piece placement this
everybody has sound I got a message that
there is a sound issue
I'm on and so I'm on the chess team
what is leech as TV the future on the
front page I think that isn't that
standard element on there okay I think
it was resolved okay so here here I can
take it I don't know probably that's an
option
this night now it doesn't have many
squares okay you playing back house okay
which is entertaining him this is an
interesting thing interesting position
yeah I know
yeah and Gustafson wasn't a TV show once
I think he was in the end a our talk
show if you're in Germany you probably
know it the pretty well-known show
German TV
well I don't really see why why such a
show would invite me but if they would I
would certainly go certainly interesting
interesting experience at the time it
was that some years ago and at the time
Yan wasn't really doing much chess and
he was doing some chess but he was
mostly I think for yeah for spoke
activities it was a it was about chess
and poker
so this must be a good position right
okay Bishop before is something that I
would like to get in with threatening
this now as well as taking on b7 with
check this is a pretty dangerous oh I
should let start do it yeah thanks for
the game creatures ideal phobia
now poker is of course luck is a huge
factor but long-term it is a skill game
definitely is playing ideal phobia
playing just very normal looking
development moves should be healthy it's
basically the copper variation with
color servers
I've played poker myself but I stopped a
long time ago almost 10 years ago yeah
I'm trying to get the tradin
let's try we can trade it yeah no it
doesn't work
yeah I tried to get this night over to
g3 and then possibly c3 and conform very
simple kind of development plan and
ideal phobia is not doing a bad job and
he's completely centralized main that
looks nice I like this position it's a
very well coordinated game that I have
let's take it Knight b6 Knight see form
is probably coming but the main point in
such a position is always if you like
this is this this is on the Queen side
and this is organizing good but you know
it's not my aid and I'm I'm on the Kings
side with with tons of pieces though
here moves all kinds of I know this
looks kind of funky but to have all
kinds of things going on that side of
the board the only bad thing about this
this rupee one is that the bishop on a2
is kind of an on piece doesn't do
anything combined okay it's it's it's
it's fine I think
maybe I should have gone
night-night h5o
maybe no it's actually suggested in the
chat yeah I think you're right now it
even looks more attractive 'i'm on all
these these pieces here being and fork
distance pre-move 27 ah I can do that
yeah thanks of the game ideal phobia
yeah I'm not really old okay I want to
do something out of the ordinary
yeah and I hope I'm not annoying people
there's a chess960 challenge let's do
that after watching the chess960 games
in Norway this is an interesting idea
one thing that I don't know is how you
actually Castle here hello to smarty
Samadhi
is probably smarty something like that I
know how drag the king over the rock
okay thank you
[Music]
okay I have to get some sort of
orientation yeah that's not easy I know
the rules there but I don't know how it
is done technically ok drag the king
over the rook I think I will get this to
get this done
black could actually go here there's no
Bishop on f1 yeah okay it's not a great
move I think c4 would have to keep it in
mind
b5 ipv4 that's actually nice so that the
Queen gets something to do my Center is
very secure that's good I like this
position I think I meant for in good
shape over f6
okay so how to do this now 93 azimuth I
need to get the bishop and castles is
that good it doesn't seem any assistance
of anything wrong with it I know I could
have probably probably taken c4 with
Knight a three and so on but this castle
in here was what attracted me because
now I have a very well coordinated
position
okay this is very hello was this close
to this pollution but I can win this
pawn because of the Queen on a aid I
played actually one chess tournament
with chess960 I was played I think two
years ago for Christmas and in a club
and in Oberhausen near my near my place
and it was an interesting interesting
event actually blast him in horde was
participating and I was here hoping to
play horde in a game of chess 960 word
and fortunately he is such a bad event
that I never got to play him and I
absolutely swear I squat for four and a
half out of five four point five out of
five so I only considered to draw in
that event and won it and I swear that I
was lost in every single game every
single game I was lost I think being
completely irritated it was the absolute
first time that I played chess 960 and
all over the board I had played it once
or twice online and I was so irritated
okay so here I'm a piss-up yeah
basically and it looks like normal chess
which helps let's activate this yeah I
guess the difference between hordes
performance and mine was that I was lost
every game but won every game almost and
he was lost in many games and lost them
somehow but I got to play hoarding in
real in real chess or in regular chess
last year there was a bit bit of a
bummer because I had a plate and a game
that I liked a lot and had a completely
winning position that I spoiled in the
deep in the end game basically by just
moving too quickly I was thinking it's
completely over and it was but I was
moving just too quickly and made a
blunder yet a really miraculous escape
in that game it isn't even the meat
somehow okay thanks for the game smart
Smarties Ahmadi
he's on touchpad yeah it's tough really
tough I couldn't do anything on a
touchpad so the wedge this game is a
little bit too long I'm for thinking
let's go for a quick one-minute game
against the drunken no I haven't beaten
him yet oh that was not intended
I wanted to play pawn to a6 of course
oh that was good but for me woof woof
okay
okay I see some chances to get on the
scoreboard against the drunken lawyer
that wasn't the parents actually that
was the feeders
yeah a pond a pond should do the trick
here we go okay at one time yes thanks
for the game TDL I am I'm your father
in chess960 yeah come on let's do it in
a in wouldn't okay
Wow is that this is the same position
that then I had earlier right
we had actually fairly normal counseling
right okay yeah thank you for the cheer
so I just got the information that it
was not precisely the same starting
position but only very similar okay
I take it I take it again okay we there
was just 960 rematch okay let's do one
rematch is that the same position
probably not
[Music]
no.not 34 I was close
let's not go NIDA for me I know it looks
a little bit weird but I wanted to get
to the Foursquare oh that's surprising
now I hear what he's opened up my bishop
here
what a strange position I gave it I
think I'm just going to cancel this is
weird right
you cancel long and there's still those
pawns on this four squares it really
looks crazy
[Music]
yeah at the end it's all about the speed
right yeah it's fun it's fun yes I'm
chess960 from time to time so who else
is on there um who else is on any
anybody who is here indigent oh wow what
the heck
thanks for the really big cheer there
Wow so what do we have
let's go I should have done shot just
960 maybe it was funny
yeah she was during the castle first
first four moves
trying to get the bishop here early on
this kind of played with them castling
on the first four moves a 93 g3 Bishop
g2 castles this is something that I was
always considering the subject that I
was considering to make a book off for a
long time and maybe I will do so at one
point I have played this kind of game a
lot
yeah with castling early on
before I try to of causes a simple
simple idea but black is easily stopped
in there
I take with the pawn maybe this is idea
yeah this is probably a good decision I
try to get this good square going for me
the knight on c4 is a nice sound feature
here yeah
just with ad/hd should play a bit
quicker here a little bit quicker it's
going to be a problem maybe later on
because the decisions now are not that
are not super crucial
[Music]
I could try b3 Bishop III I think I'll
do like yeah this looks like it could be
annoying for black an interesting point
here is that I have not played h3
interesting play here of like Knight you
for maybe he wants to cancel long and
simply play on the edge farm that a
splits possible okay if I go Bishop b3
there's no G for
that's an interesting idea absolutely
yeah thanks a lot for helping out with
the with help with helping wow this is a
difficult thing things in the chat for
helping out with the questions of new
players like how to challenge me and so
on sometimes difficult to do you had to
play the games and pay attention to
those things as well so it's great if
you you help them so my idea is that
this now yeah I'd like to go Bishop me
through EBIT
I wonder if how I should play this I can
also do this and then we should be three
so that 94 can be answered with Bishop
h3 like if he goes here I have this
which I did sorry which I didn't have
before
okay and to put this here and now Knight
g4 Bishop age 3 is a thing and I haven't
installed any chat board no it's
probably something to look into
[Music]
yeah black is doing all right
see it's playing this fine I don't have
a great deal of activity here I can try
to double
I think I'm doubling okay I don't know
doubling on the H file I don't know if
that helps really
my idea now is to play here oh that
cannot work like panicked a little bit
there with the clock ticking down is the
best is probably to first attack the
Queen and only then take it so the Queen
cannot even enter the game
okay there was a pre move probably yeah
okay I think if you don't take on a joy
it wasn't so it wasn't so bad you know
only four I mean I'm not sure how this
is a bad position I mean I should be a
bit better but a normal move probably is
so kind of okay thanks for the game it
was really interesting it was very
creative with long chasm and I think I
was interesting so who else is on the
wedge is on for a long time but this is
a bit long that's a bit long I think I
wanted to do three minute most peanut
double-oh-seven so I don't know if you
guys liked the chess960 games if you if
you did challenge me to chess960 we can
play a couple I'm really kind of curious
to to try it out
interesting now we transpose to him
isolated to an isolated pawn position
very likely okay no I think no joke
you're onto something chess960 I'm not
sure that it dry is the right word but I
think they are sometimes um there is
usually many of those positions are not
very dynamic yeah there is a little
early conflict because sometimes the
pieces are so oddly placed that you
first need to kind of get some harmony
into them and then it gets interesting
[Music]
but yeah some of the solid positions are
just damn awkward I have the same
opinion I mean I mean I wouldn't say dry
and I'm not dry so it would it's just
like sometimes like it's a bit stodgy
and a little bit weird but but there are
I mean in the eye I watched some of them
the games between Magnus and and
Nakamura and I think that was really
interesting
I watched I've watched a bit of them the
the final day that when they played is
somewhat slower through blitz
I had an idea with this that peanuts did
not really appreciate then I think there
is um a bit of lack of harmony in some
random positions I think it really is I
mean what-what I sometimes feels like if
you if you have a let's say a regular
chess position a standard chess position
I think due to the opening choices and
the different very much different types
of positions that you can get like an
idol of what dragon Sicilian is a very
typical flair to it let's say um they
are so different it's a completely
different game if you play like let's
say an idol or you play you play a
Queen's Gambit Laska variation it's just
it's just entirely different and it
sometimes feels like if you review if
you put chess as if you see chess as a
form of art it sometimes it feels a bit
to me like we're talking them we're
talking about different types of music
let's say yeah and then just not 60 it
sometimes feels like just it starts with
some some kind of undefined noise and
you need to get some harmony into it
first this is actually hey that's so far
away from normal chess the kingside is
completely identical we just have this
is a bit different that that that will
look like a fairly regular position
quickly
that that can that looks like that will
look like a Reggie opening quite quickly
actually funny
I wonder if this is an idea
oh that's it yeah but yeah I can take F
665 and have a greedy really guy I'll
take that
the reason is why I took it is that this
is completely dominating the night on
the eighth and it's not easy an awful
black to coordinate that at least that's
how I see it which could be wrong but I
think I even this is some sort of a
threat now okay we should be sadness
okay
[Music]
okay I've got you come to this end I'm
keeping the d5 pawn as long as I do that
the 928 will be in a tough spot
maybe black should try to play the
b-pawn which after the six would give me
the exchange but I'm not sure that I
want to take the rook in the corner it's
it's maybe a sorry b5 maybe instead
maybe beehive yeah he plays that like I
suggested and I think it's a good idea
but I don't have to take it I rather
want to develop there should be seven
castles I have to do it yeah okay I have
to put it on rook
to be honest to be honest the Berlin end
game the end game version of the Berlin
I actually think is somewhat interesting
I don't think it's totally uninteresting
in the Berlin the rule of pest Berlin I
think the more boring variation is
actually the rupee one line which is
incredibly boring
this is feels like the super super
stodgy version of the French exchange
for black where you really feel like
yeah I just just like completely
completely and utterly join us to play I
mean it's equal but it's absolutely no
fun okay the night is still on d8
I go rook c1 and possibly night b54
night see set up suite 497
what's the idea at least okay so let's
do let's evaluate just a little bit yeah
I go enjoy don't you get more activity
him I could have [ __ ] rooks really
[Music]
maybe so if he takes it politics would
be good so you know black is on six
seconds
oh I did not see that
he's got he's got the check on the back
ring and then I have to go Bishop
everyone and then Bishop a6 this is a
bit of an issue
[Music]
okay I probably still have to do it
one problem is that he's threatening
mate
Bishop h3 will need to mate
I played this in a bit of a silly
fashion rally d6 was probably not good
yeah my dad was also not good now the
bishop is essentially not playing at all
now now I was winning a long time and I
was I didn't know I played this far too
quickly with the CAPTCHA on a five yeah
thanks for the game t-bone there are
still some other 960 challenges
this is untidy again
[Music]
Dutch almost Dutch
who do I wait isn't that a pond
yes I won upon the joys of chess960
winning in early porn what see forth and
somehow know our so they also do other
challenges but it was interesting to do
a couple of chess960 each walkie I have
to get this Bishop into the game like
here the Knight to g4
not quite over here that looks good can
I actually could i castlelong here
probably yes yeah if the queen is that
say queen fo I could cancel long I'm too
curious to try them now I can do it
right the king is not crossing this yeah
so it works more than Prime may be the
best move but I was simply too curious
if it is a legal move and it isn't legal
move I try this next
it looks an actor and I to Hanks okay so
I would absolutely like to get the five
in on the road together this cannot be
bad
well okay it can be bad but it looks
like a good improving move
just be annoying I one day 44 is good
Queen b5 would just be that doesn't do
all that much a book on opening theory
which is for chestnuts exam probably not
[Music]
slightly sense I live for one more
threats well I mean okay living for one
more thread sounds a bit one-sided it
immediately but I think actually that
simply avoiding short move mistakes like
blunder material or yeah put something
kind of but I think my position is okay
it looks a bit critical and see far if
you avoid the one move blunders that is
already an enormous playing strength
yeah I kind of had the idea could be a
bit tricky I really would like to play
king b8 so that I'm not blundering stuff
yeah thanks for the game bore of Nitze a
bore of Nika
okay so Pete was Antonia versus also
changed her leg and let's get this solid
it looks like I can do the Kings vehicle
oh I'm not really into hyper bullets
that much
Pedro's antonius is not playing so you
can always challenge me again later so
fishy fishy
let's get going here I have to get a
little bit of believe aww look first
yeah let's do it
therefore I try to give some spacey to
my bishop on g1 yam
now he says he wants to spend a moment
this is a very long castles right the
short castle is very long he says he
wants to spend a moment to look at the
position why not we can do that and by
the way I'm on for close to two hours
now and I'm not going to be on super
long today maybe for half an hour or
something and then I have to have to
quit I have to do something really early
tomorrow and I cannot stay on for a
super long however I can I will play
some non chess960 after this game and
for is hanging
this looks valuable I think he actually
wants to play Bishop to h7 so I'm
countering this and I'm preparing me for
let's go eat four and must but would be
four d4 Bishop is recheck it would be
strong but I'm far away from doing that
okay f5 though it must be good to know
the bishop PM is not great on h7
yeah dd5 is a huge space gainer by let's
do it it's too much space to to not play
at let's say okay so night to III or how
to do this there is just six somewhat on
the cards okay
I have to keep in mind that we are not
talking playing with a document here
that was a good move that was really
good news
so we have long castles for both of us
Bishop 287 is probably coming
[Music]
and try to put pressure onto these six
and this these trades I think help to
get to those weak spots the thing that
somehow I have I have this hunch that
there is something possible against my
center not sure completely but it looks
a lot like it
going for Luke c1 next it still has that
absolutely terrible
no ah great
that's great yeah from I mean sorry this
position was winning four wide almost
with the dead Bishop and now I've
learned a piece by the mouse live what
is dead in such a shame it's such a
shame you know him you just play here
she takes and the bishop 187 is dead
we'll never do anything in this game
yeah I had to speed up a little bit
because of the time that position is
really bad for like I get rook c1 and
the night on b6 means that I always keep
the C file under control so I was really
happy with this game went so ok so I
will play a couple of more games and I
have to do sorry I have to do this one
so let's get going
this is actually an old club made of
mine and we know each other since my
very first days of playing chess so
since the late 1980s let's see what's
going on here
I don't really like to propose
take-backs
I also accept them if they're if the
mouth lips are obvious but I don't ask
for them it just happens
yeah I try to occupy the center black
played a little bit of an anon he five
that's a very drastic way of doing it I
can take this and also just take the
pawn right what's the deal this is the
idea I can take here play h3
Age 3
he doesn't have square saying yes to go
to age 6 now basically if I'm not
mistaken as its so a little bit a little
bit odd but 9 age 6 I go efore and keep
the knight out of the game
and fortunately haven't watched any of
the Olympics somehow it's just not part
of my routine to sit and sit in front of
a TV or just completely not what I'm
doing
this is a position where gasoline long
looks funky if he takes Queen takes I
can play I didn't see that this was
hanging and it was just too tempting and
to do the long castles okay but still it
feels like I've got an attack here I
have to shake this I think twenty four
is actually giving me a good game but it
is very lame between before doesn't do
much sacrifice also doesn't too much he
six is an idea okay I have effect I keep
forgetting that this is three minutes
yes I have simply take too long I had a
huge clock advantage which is now gone
[Music]
yeah that's always funny if you allow a
take-back and then you make a most
ablator and they decline that that's
always cool this is like the big screw
you we have yeah then it's kind of
comparable to my Monica's games he would
try it he would play everything on time
every position look against hook and so
on but when he's got a slightly worse
endgame and you have more time on the
clock he will beg for a draw the whole
time this is really really funny yeah
thanks for the game royal blue Oh for
I'm actually giving him a rematch this
is really a special kind of game we
don't play all that often so and he's a
good player by the way it's a feat of
Marseille yeah it's not a not a bad play
at all
so whoosh Oh what are you doing this is
a gambit gambit style white has a pretty
decent development though no that could
be easily enough compensation
going Dutch
- bitter ugly I admit that
but why doesn't have very obvious choice
as him not to be 5 is certainly coming
and definitely annoying short
kastlevilla he canceled long okay
hmm canceling sure that we would like to
do that but but you have to if you sort
my pieces a little bit I don't think
that was possible
while I'd say I didn't think it was all
that grade 95 is actually quite tempting
let's do it I wonder if Queen to a6 is
good
[Music]
anyway I have to take it
how my development somehow my kinks
making position is giving me some
uncomfortable moments could I actually
still Castle short I could cancel short
here right
I mean theoretically speaking I could
cancel short like here that would be
really really funny it's not a good move
but it's fun to play okay so I grab
stuff ah come on it's just so funny
those castles are completely crazy I'm
pretty sure he's having a laugh at
valide that's really funny okay
let's trade Queens okay he doesn't want
you understandably so
yeah thanks for the game royal blue okay
no that was fun some cool castles okay
so what this is what about the clock 20
minutes who else is on deviator is
changing into a three check okay let's
do next one game of three check this is
a funky one and I don't know if I can
actually play this and some sort of
decent quality yeah thanks for being
wrong styling it was probably not bad
yet you're to take I played a couple of
this games
yeah sorry I played a couple three check
maybe five or six games some time ago
and I didn't really get anywhere now
this has got to be a check right at
least one check I will get for not much
you can almost certainly take on d3 not
sure if taking on g2 is that great
that's right that's the first check
[Music]
yeah this disis nights six stuff I saw
actually one tournament of was some
games in an entry check when I qubits in
in one of the tournaments and they
played like that it looked sensible oh
no this is a good idea but doesn't look
like he's going to check me that quickly
okay and I'd be 597 is probably a threat
so let's take it look almost like
regular chess here this I guess I can't
help it
try to March the h-bond down the board
I'm a bit down on time but it's one
second increments oh it feels like
unlimited time almost covered this
he might get a check with this kind of
thing qui gh4 is super dangerous it
would have been extremely dangerous at
the time
that looks like shakes galore coming
rather that's over yeah it's it's check
and it's made next movie so yeah thanks
for the game deviator why why to YT
YouTube probably um so let's go for one
more game the experiment tater from
position okay oh my god and I don't play
this horde stuff usually okay
with time control is that three plus
five
how many pawns is that by the way it's a
lot right
Wow
it feels extremely extremely weird of
course
and you think do you think that white is
completely winning a.m. maybe hits many
pots lots of bones
I've never played this horde thing not
too knowledgeable about the variance I
know it's a ton of points against the
irregular starting position
so in hordeum in what there is no king
how do you win then against the pawns by
taking the moral law
[Laughter]
maybe I just have to sit actually and I
mean he's kind of not saying in suits
varmint he has to push those pawns
forward which yeah is also an issue of
course
yeah I don't know if this is good yeah
but getting a bit of space here at least
it's fairly easy to blunder stuff
somehow it's just so weird
maybe have to get it night somewhere
think something like the head
yeah I'm running out of pawns I don't
have many points left
okay it's really I want to want him to
go a bit more fan he has so many ports
it's really really tough IAM unless he
blunders some of them
he just pushes everything forward slowly
a way to have a try c6 next
our counseling might be dangerous but I
mean I think this is just totally lost
from the very start they're just too
many bonds
too many phones yeah castling was
probably bad you know that it it is
probably again totally lost from the
start I wonder if if I have some kind of
chick on this long diagonal we can still
put so many pawns in front of it you
know what I just recognized I have to
somehow get yeah yeah what here there's
a desert thing in the Chad stop
he says stock fish prefers favors of the
lucky at the beginning of the game I
have a hard time believing that but
maybe it's a draw with perfect player I
don't know
[Music]
I wonder I would need to get the Queen
behind enemy lines that same
[Music]
I have to do something like that it was
suggested in the chat and I would have
done that anyway I think I'm taking one
before I could have okay but now wait
I've checked here that that this is
taking a turn for the worse for wet yes
ah good game I have no clue but it's
what's crazy it was absolutely crazy I
don't know
okay okay we do it once we do it once
with with with them reversed reversed
colors so let's do this once here for
the final game of the session and I
cannot believe that it's a draw in
perfect play
let's do this once and then call it Dave
um okay
[Music]
oh wow
didn't see that one coming
[Music]
okay so d6 I don't know
poets on the first and second rank can
move two squares okay I have no clue
what I'm trying to do which is I don't
know if it's a good idea I try to simply
get these pawns up so that there are
more pawns in front of the King and then
like deep this sorry this this this this
yeah I have no idea of this is a good
strategy meant
then we will also find out if you can
move two squares from the starting
position okay
happy to take it
okay now I'm curious
can I really play d1 to d3 next and this
even
okay I know I think he gives me too much
material there it's probably not good
for black anyway of it it feels
excessive no not possible not possible
okay now I'm happy with my king position
getting back safely
can I can I actually promote or is that
forbidden
[Music]
I assume I'm playing just from a
position so this is normal normal rules
so there should be a promotion of pawns
possible as I say I always use the king
it doesn't quite work Tempe Weiss right
and now I have to meet him yeah
otherwise otherwise it's a stalemate
okay it was funny once a game so yeah we
only have two or three challenges left
but I'm happy to stop the stream now I
have to get up early and need a bit of
sleep I don't want to fall asleep
tomorrow morning thanks for watching
things for all of you being you to the
to the stream I'll be back
definitely on Monday with the Monday
night live show maybe something on
Saturday or Sunday but this is rather
sorry a spontaneous decision if there is
time or not
thanks a lot and until Monday at least
bye bye